welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday
[Music]
life I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a
professor of neurobiology and
Opthalmology at Stanford school of
medicine today we are talking about goal
setting and achieving goals now we've
done three full episodes about this
topic previously I did a solo episode
about this topic where I described the
Neuroscience of the circuitry in the
brain and body that underlies goal
setting and pursuit I also hosted two
expert guests who have done extensive
research on these topics those guests
were Dr Emily baltis from New York
University and Dr MAA Shankar so today's
episode is going to focus on the key
takeaways from those three previous
episodes as well as incorporate new
information that has been published in
the scientific literature since those
episodes aired so that by the end of
today's episode you will have a potent
tool kit for setting and pursuing goals
we will talk about how to select which
goals to pursue and when we will talk
about how to measure your progress we
will talk about how to initiate and
sustain motivation as you pursue your
goals we are also going to dispel some
prominent myths about goal setting in
Pursuit given that this is a toolkit
episode I will talk about some of the
underlying biological mechanisms for the
protocols that I describe but most of
what I will cover are the protocols
themselves the how to identify a goal
select the best goal for you to pursue
how to initiate goal Pursuit how to
maintain goal Pursuit how to evaluate
progress and how to do the post Hawk
analysis after you achieve a goal or as
the case may be not achieve a goal
although I'm confident that if you
implement even a subset of the protocols
that we cover today that you stand the
greatest possible chance of both setting
the proper goal and achieving that goal
and I can say that both with confidence
Ence and humility because the protocols
I describe were not created by me they
are gleaned from the scientific
peer-reviewed literature and they have
been shown to work before we begin I'd
like to emphasize that this podcast is
separate from my teaching and research
roles at Stanford it is however part of
my desire and effort to bring zero cost
to Consumer information about science
and science related tools to the general
public in keeping with that theme I'd
like to thank the sponsors of today's
podcast our first sponsor is eight sleep
eight sleep makes Smart match covers
with cooling Heating and sleep tracking
capacity sleep is the foundation of
mental health physical health and
performance when we're sleeping well and
enough everything in life goes much
better and when we aren't sleeping well
or long enough things in life get worse
we know that from data we all know that
from our own experience one of the
essential things to getting a great
night's sleep is that the temperature of
your sleeping environment needs to be
such that your core body temperature
drops by about 1 to 3° in order to fall
and stay deeply asleep and then in
increase by 1 to 3° in order to wake up
feeling refreshed in the morning with
eights sleep smart mattress covers you
can program the temperature of your
sleeping environment so that it's
ideally matched to your temperature
needs I started sleeping on an eight-
Sleep mattress cover a few years ago and
it has completely transformed the
quality of the sleep that I get so much
so that I actually loathe traveling
because I don't have my eights Sleep
mattress cover when I travel if you'd
like to try eight sleep you can go to
8sleep.com
huberman and you'll save up to $150 off
their pod 3 cover eight sleep currently
ships in the USA Canada UK select
countries in the EU and Australia again
that's 8sleep.com
huberman today's episode is also brought
To Us by Maui Nei venison Maui Nei
venison is the most nutrient-dense and
delicious red meat available I've spoken
before on this podcast in Solo episodes
and with guests about the need to get
approximately one gram of highquality
protein per pound of body weight each
day for optimal nutrition now there are
many different ways that one can do that
but a key thing is to make sure that
you're not doing that by ingesting
excessive calories Maui Nei venison has
the highest density of quality protein
per calorie and it achieves that in
delicious things like ground Meats
venison steaks jerky and bone broth I
particularly like the ground venison I
make those into venison burgers probably
five times a week or more I also like
the jerky for its convenience especially
when I'm traveling or I'm especially
busy with work and know that I'm getting
an extremely nutrient-dense high quality
source of protein if you'd like to try
Maui neui venison you can go to mauii
Venison
docomo and get 20% off your first order
again that's Maui venison
docomond to get 20% off okay let's talk
about goal setting and pursuit and as I
mentioned a few minutes ago this is a
toolkit episode so I'm not going to talk
too much about the mechanistic
underpinnings of the protocols for goal
setting and pursuit I'm mostly just
going to give you those protocols but
before I do that I want to take just
three minutes I promise just 3 minutes
or less and describe the neural
circuitry involved in goal setting and
pursuit and there are two reasons to do
that first of all the biology of goal
setting and pursuit is absolutely
beautiful it's incredible that we and
many other animals in fact have this
neural circuitry and that it works in
the way that it does but equally
important is that when we have a
mechanistic understanding or framework
for how a protocol or set of protocols
work it makes it much easier to tweak
those protocols and customize them to
our unique needs okay so with that said
the goal setting and pursuit circuitry
essentially consists of four major
stations in the brain although it's
important to point out that each of
those stations has a number of other
connections that are important for the
whole goal setting and pursuit process
but we can distill things down to four
major hubs or stations within the brain
and those are the basil ganglia the
lateral prefrontal cortex and the
orbital frontal cortex so going through
those one by one the amydala is a
structure within the brain you actually
have two of them one on each side of the
brain that is involved in circuits
associated with arousal in driving
levels of alertness it's also involved
in fear you've probably heard that many
times before but also things like
anxiety and actually the amydala can be
involved in what we call positive
veilance experiences not just the bad
stuff like fear and anxiety but also
positive forms of arousal and even
learning the basil ganglia include a lot
of different brain structures but for
sake of today's discussion what you need
to know is that the basil ganglia
includes two major Pathways one is the
so-called go pathway which is the
pathway involved in generating actions
and the other is the so-called no-go
pathway or the pathway involved in
withholding or ceasing action and this
is really important to understand
because with all goals we have to ask
ourselves are we trying to learn how to
do something new or are we trying to
withhold a certain set of actions and of
course any time we learn anything it's a
process of both generating and
withholding certain actions so we've got
the amydala and we have the basil
ganglia which has this go action
initiating and no go action withholding
circuitry within it and then there's the
lateral prefrontal cortex which is
involved in immediate and long-term
planning and this is going to be a key
component of today's discussion because
we aren't going to be talking about
lateral prefrontal cortex per se but we
are going to be talking about time
perception in the context of setting and
achieving our goals because setting and
achieving our goals is all about being
able to orient both in space knowing
where we are and what we're doing but
also in time know where we are in that
road of progress toward achieving our
goal or crossing that finish line and
repeatedly updating those Finish Lines
in many cases and the fourth structure
is the orbital frontal cortex which like
all brain areas tends to be a
multitasker it does a bunch of different
things but for sake of today's
discussion it's important to understand
that the orbital frontal cortex is
involved in evaluation of our current
emotional state and arousal state
as it relates to our goal Pursuit for
instance are we happy because we are
sensing progress or are we unhappy and
feeling frustrated or sad or angry
because we are feeling that we are not
achieving progress or that somehow we
can't get into the sorts of actions that
are going to allow us to eventually
reach our goals okay so I described four
major structures all of which
communicate with each other and of
course a lot of other brain areas and
those four structures were the amydala
the basil ganglia the go and no-o
circuitry the lateral prefrontal cortex
and the orbital frontal cortex and those
represent the core components of the
neural circuitry involved in goal
setting and pursuit now I realize I
didn't time that section so I don't know
whether or not it was 3 minutes or less
but if it was shorter than 3 minutes
great and if it was longer than 3
minutes well I promise to shave a couple
minutes off the end of this episode okay
so now you have the understanding that
we all have the same neural circuitry
for goal setting and pursuit I find that
amazing regardless of whether or not you
want to achieve a fit Fitness goal or an
academic goal or a work goal monetary
goal relationship goal maybe you want to
just get better at relaxing I've been
told I should perhaps pursue that goal
well you're going to use the same neural
circuits for each and any of those I
find that incredible I also find that
very reassuring because what it means is
that if we can focus on the tools and
protocols that are anchored in the
biology of goal setting and pursuit as
we understand them to exist in all
humans and indeed in other animals as
well well then we should have the
greatest possible confidence that we
will in fact achieve our goals so how do
we go about doing that well the first
question you need to ask yourself is
what goal do I want to pursue and the
first protocol for deciding what goal
you want to pursue is actually a quite
simple one in terms of How It's stated
but it's fairly complex for a lot of
people to answer and that is which
specific goal are you going to try and
pursue because guess what folks most
people who trying to achieve many goals
simultaneously fail at all of them this
is what I call the overhaul approach
when people think okay you know in
January 1 or next month or next week or
perhaps even today I'm going to start
exercising I'm going to start meditating
I'm going to learn a language I'm going
to learn to dance I'm going to do all
these different things and that's just
too many goals I think here is an
appropriate place to highlight the word
priority a priority literally means one
thing that you place ahead of all others
these days we hear a lot about
priorities plural but we really should
be thinking about priority and defining
our priority for learning in a given
phase so if you are somebody who wants
to get more physically fit or you want
to learn something cognitively that's
terrific you are allowed to have
multiple goals but I highly recommend
that you first select just one goal of
course you don't let go of other aspects
of your mental health and physical
health that you don't throw your life
away in service to this one goal goal
we've all seen how that goes and it's
not a britty picture but rather that you
continue to engage in healthy ways with
the other aspects of your life that
you're proficient at or mostly
proficient at but that you select one
goal that you're going to try and attain
how you select that one goal of course
it's going to reflect your values your
motivation your resources but it's very
important that you spend some serious
time defining that one priority that one
goal for this initial goal setting and
Pursuit period and in a moment I'll tell
you how long that goal Pursuit period
ought to be but for some people the best
way to define which goal they're going
to pursue is to write out the different
things that they want and then
essentially cross off the various things
that they're willing to put on hold for
the time being and circle the thing that
they're really going to focus on and
only that thing and again this is highly
individual it's going to depend on you
your past your present your future your
resources all of that but having that
one priority is is going to really
increase the probability that you're
going to achieve your goal now we also
know from the scientific literature that
how lofty that goal is will impact
whether or not you are able to achieve
it and I think most people mistakenly
believe that if a goal is easy to
achieve it's more likely that they will
achieve that goal sort of a duh but in
fact the opposite has been shown to be
true if a goal is too easy to achieve it
seems that it doesn't recruit sufficient
amounts of the arousal Network that
involves the amydala but a bunch of
other brain structures as well that get
people into the necessary actions to
continually pursue that goal this
perhaps should not be surprising in
order to learn something we have to
shift our nervous system into states
that are somewhat uncomfortable these
should be safely uncomfortable States
but they should be uncomfortable States
and we're going to talk more about this
as the episode continues but any kind of
successful learning or goal Pursuit is
going to involve errors it's it's going
to involve failures it's going to
involve frustration it's going to
involve anxiety all of those states of
Mind and Body in fact shift the brain
into modes of so-called neuroplasticity
they give it the ability to change and
that should make perfect sense because
if you can complete what you need to do
easily there's absolutely no reason for
the neural circuitry in your brain or
body to shift in any way why would it
rather those states of discomfort
frustration anxiety Etc
represent shifts in neurochemical states
that literally open the opportunity for
neuroplasticity to occur the changes
between neurons that allow those neurons
and their Associated neural circuits to
perform differently in the future when
we learn something so the key here is
twofold first Define the specific
priority goal that you're going to
pursue and set aside all other goal
Pursuits and in doing that it makes
sense to pursue a somewhat loftier goal
than perhaps a more mundane goal or if
you know exactly what goal you're going
to prioritize that you try and Achieve
perhaps more than you think you ought to
be able to achieve within that given
goal and within the goal that you decide
to prioritize you want to set a level of
progress a level of performance that
you're striving to attain that's a bit
above what you actually believe at this
time you can accomplish now in doing so
you are inevitably going to encounter
some frustration and anxiety but
remember the component of the neural
circuitry that we talked about at the
beginning of the episode the orbital
frontal cortex that orbital frontal
cortex is not just part of a neural
circuitry that assesses how we feel in a
given moment as we are trying to pursue
a goal but it also understands context
it has the capacity to for instance see
that you are experiencing anxiety know
that you are frustrated but now that you
understand that anxiety and frustration
that comes with making errors is
actually the Gateway it's a necessary
gateway to achieving neural circuit
changes so-call
neuroplasticity well the orbital frontal
cortex understands that context it
literally can take information about
neuroplasticity it can take information
about frustration which you now have and
it can combine those such that when you
experience that frustration you
experience those errors and you
previously would have wanted to quit now
you know that you are literally making
progress you're literally shifting those
neural circuits in the direction of
improved learning now it's also
important to remind that neuroplasticity
the changes in neural circuits that
allow for improved performance in the
future does not occur instantaneously
that frustration that occurs during our
attempts to learn or to pursue a goal is
the trigger for neuroplasticity the
actual rewiring of neural circuits that
allows for proficient correct
performance occurs during deep sleep and
other forms of deep rest this is
something I've covered extensively in
episodes on neuroplasticity and learning
and if you you'd like to learn more
about neuroplasticity in fact if you'd
like a zeroc cost toolkit that defines
the so-called super protocol for
neuroplasticity and learning that is not
just nested within the context of goal
Pursuit and learning we have that you
can go to hubman lab.com you go to the
menu go scroll down to newsletter and
you can sign up it's completely zero
cost and you'll get that as a brief I
believe it's a two or maybe three page
PDF okay so returning to goal setting
and pursuit first you need to set your
goal you really should take the time
required to Define your priority what
are you going to try and learn and then
you're going to pick a goal that really
feels challenging that feels like it
might even be Out Of Reach because that
will recruit the neural circuits
associated with arousal they're
motivating enough to get you into action
now I want to be very clear I'm not
suggesting that you pick a goal that's
impossible to achieve or that you
believe is impossible to achieve that's
not going to serve you well rather I'm
saying pick a goal that feels just a bit
Out Of Reach and don't obsess too much
about whether or not it's a lot out of
reach or a little bit Out Of Reach pick
something you're excited to pursue that
you would really like to accomplish set
that goal and then just set aside all
other goals still of course maintain or
improve other aspects of your life that
are necessary for daily living for
mental health physical health Etc but
really just focus on one goal I promise
that you will be far more satisfied with
the results if you can truly set a
priority so once you've defined the
specific goal that you are going to
prioritize there are two more things
things that you need to do before you
start to pursue that goal the first one
is that you need to define the specific
verbs the actions that are involved in
pursuing that goal this is absolutely
critical a lot of people will set a sort
of title goal or a goal State they'll
say oh you know I want to be rich or I
want to be smart or they will say I want
to be fit or proficient in a given
language it's really important that you
put additional specificity on your goal
in fact it's important that you put a
lot of specificity on your goal and that
you focus mainly on verbs when defining
that specificity now there are a lot of
reasons for this that have to do both
with increasing the probability that you
will achieve your goal as well as
maintaining motivation as you pursue
that goal so for instance rather than
saying you want to be fit or you want to
be a better Runner or swimmer you would
want to get very specific about the verb
that you're going to engage in order to
achieve that goal now it's somewhat
obvious in the case of running or
swimming I think everyone understands
that if you want to be a better Runner
there is going to be some running
involved if you want to be a better
swimmer there's going to be some
swimming involved of course but
presumably there will be some other
behaviors as well everything from
driving to the pool or lacing up your
shoes I mean there's an essentially near
infinite number of verbs involved in any
type of goal Pursuit so what we are
talking about here is really defining
the goal on a piece of paper and I do
think that's important you should write
this down and I think the process of
selecting your goal that priority as
well as defining the specificity of the
verb action that you're going to pursue
should be done on paper you of course
are going to think but then you should
write it out seeing things on paper and
writing them out by hand with pen or
pencil really has been shown to engage
neural circuitry in a way that is
different than typing with your thumbs
into your phone which by the way is a
new feature of human evolution I do
believe this is the first time in human
evolution that we have written with our
thumbs I don't know I don't have a time
machine I can't go back and check but
I'm willing to place a bet that that
statement is correct so the point is
that writing things out is not only
important it's also the most effective
way to embed knowledge in our nervous
system so I highly recommend that you
write things out on a piece of paper in
your process of goal setting so when we
are talking about generating verb
specificity about your goal it would
look like the following so let's say I
want to to quote unquote get more fit or
learn conversational French or anything
for that matter gardening maybe I want
to build a gazebo in the backyard or a
deck in the backyard the key thing to
answer is what is the major block of
action that's going to be involved in
pursuing that goal so for instance if
you want to get more fit and you're
going to do that primarily through
running and weight training or swimming
and weight training you would want to
get very specific in defining that
priority goal as I'm going to run X
number of miles per week or I'm going to
go to the gym three times per week to
lift weights although I would recommend
getting even more specific than that I
would recommend that you literally write
down I'm going to go to the gym three
times per week for a minimum of 60
minutes where 50 minutes of that are
carrying out hard work okay with of
course rest between sets Etc or I'm
going to attend three classes per week
or perhaps even just one class per week
of learning conversational French plus
I'm going to spend two hours per week of
practicing say word problems or
mathematical problems whatever it is you
want to Define first the priority then
you want to define the verb action that
represents the bulk of effort towards
that priority so running in the case of
the person who wants to get fit by
running weightlifting in the case of the
person that wants to get fit by
weightlifting though of course I highly
recommend people do both resistance
training and uh cardiovascular training
if indeed they want to be truly fit or
in the case of language learning or
learning how to code or gardening or
something of that sort to really Define
the verb actions involved and then to
place specificity in terms of the amount
of time that one is going to try to
achieve each week in pursuit of that
specific priority goal now I realize
that that process itself takes a bit of
time but when you look back on the
100-year plus scientific literature of
what leads to success uccessful goal
setting and pursuit you find over and
over again that those two components
we've been talking about specificity and
measurability are Paramount you just
simply cannot discard those from the
process if you expect yourself to
achieve your goals so whether or not
it's the ABC method or it's the smart
method or the smarter method again all
acronyms coined not by me but by others
previous to this conversation you're
going to find elements of specificity
and measurability showing up again and
again so these are key features of any
protocol that you are going to use in
order to try and set and achieve your
goals and I should mention that setting
specific goals and clearly defining the
verbs that you're are going to engage in
to pursue those goals and defining how
long you are going to try and engage in
those verbs each week to achieve those
goals has significant impact on the
probability of success we're not talking
about a minor effect in fact in the
original episode I did about goal
setting and pursuit I talked about the
so-called recycling study I'm not going
to describe it in a lot of detail right
now but essentially this study looked at
motivating people to recycle more
recyclable products in the workplace and
what they found was that when people
were told what the specific goal was and
what specific actions they needed to
engage in were and how much of a given
batch of refu so say you know after
lunch there's some boxes or some Forks
Etc some napkins how much of that refu
they were going to try to put into the
recycle versus the trash it led to a
greater than doubling of successful
achievement of that goal now that's a
perhaps trivial goal to some of you
although let's face it recycling is
important but that result has been shown
again and again and again for different
domains of goal setting and pursuit so
this thing of setting specificity really
spending time with it on paper setting
specificity of actions of which specific
actions and then setting specificity of
how long you are going to engage in each
of those actions each week greatly
increases the probability that you will
achieve that what previously seemed to
be a all too lofty goal earlier I
mentioned that during the course of
today's episode we were going to dispel
some common myths about goal setting and
pursuit so now I'd like to mention two
popular myths about goal setting and
pursuit the first one is that if we set
a Post-It you know a little Post-it
sticky where you write down what you're
trying to achieve and you put that on
the refrigerator or you put that on your
mirror that it increases the probability
that you are going to stick to your goal
turns out that is not the case and the
reason for that is that your visual
system adapts to whatever is regular in
your environment doesn't matter whether
or not that environment is sparse so it
only has a few things in it or whether
or not it is dense like a forest
anything that shows up regularly in our
visual environment gets canceled out
this is actually a basic feature of the
way your visual system is wired so for
those of you that are taking a sticky
note or a magnet or a sign and putting
it on your mirror and leaving it there
from day to day maybe that says you know
run 60 minutes today or study French 20
minutes or whatever the goal happens to
be if you leave it there day today today
it actually diminishes the likelihood of
progress I know that seems kind of hard
to believe but it's true instead a
better approach is is to continually
write that thing out each day and put up
a new sticky put it in a new place
perhaps on the refrigerator sometimes in
the kitchen maybe on the windshield of
your car although of course remove that
while you're driving Etc if you are
going to incorporate visual reminders in
your goal setting and goal Pursuit
process you want to change those each
and every day this is actually something
that uh perhaps app developers will
start to incorporate because I think the
notifications that come through on
various apps designed to remind us to do
certain things can be helpful but there
too we tend to attenuate to them and we
simply either do not notice them or we
start to swipe them away over time so
visual reminders can be very effective
if you want to use them great you
certainly don't have to but if you're
going to use them you want to update
them every single day otherwise your
visual system and certainly the areas of
your brain that are associated with
assessing novelty and emotionality will
simply start to cancel those away so the
first common myth that we're dispelling
is what I call the poit fallacy the the
idea that if you write something down on
a Post-It and you post it in an area
that you frequent every morning or every
day or every night that you stand a
higher probability of adhering to what
is on that Post-it that is simply not
true you would want to replace it every
day and you would also be wise to move
that Post-it to different locations the
second myth is that if you want to
increase your motivation toward pursuing
a goal and you want to increase the
probability that you will achieve that
goal that you should engage in so-called
accountability meaning that you should
tell people you are going to achieve
that goal now I realize that there are
some prominent examples in pop culture
of people posting something on social
media and saying you know in three years
I'm going to be you know playing in
Wembley Stadium or in two years watch
I'm going to be at the top level of my
game whatever that game happens to be
sure there are examples of that and
those are beautiful and inspiring
examples however the scientific data
tell us that if we inform people around
us that for instance we are going to
write a book or that we're going to
start a podcast or that we are going to
run a marathon or whatever it happens to
be more often than not we get feedback
that is generally positive inform I
think that's good and to be expected
frankly you know if a friend tells us
hey I'm going to write a book or I'm
going to pursue a new fitness goal or
I'm going to learn a language we say
great go for it you can totally do it
you're very likely to succeed go for it
how do you want me to support you as a
there anything I can do to support you
those all are frankly healthy exchanges
and yet the data tell us that the
positive feedback that we get from
others when we announce that we're going
after a goal activate certain reward
systems and motivation systems within
our brain that then quickly dissipate
and then diminish the probability that
we'll engage in the type of behaviors
that actually lead us to achieve that
goal so we have the posit fallacy and we
have the myth of accountability fallacy
within the context of goal Pursuit I of
course am not saying that accountability
is bad to the contrary accountability is
a great thing both to ourselves and to
others it's something that we should all
cultivate throughout life I'm merely
talking about the myth of accountability
in the context of goal Pursuit and I'm
actually being more specific than that
I'm saying don't tell people that you're
going to go out and Achieve something
prior to initiating action toward that
goal because in fact the positive
feedback that we get will diminish the
probability that we will continually
pursue that goal in a way that allows us
to achieve it so you could interpret the
information I just gave you as meaning
that perhaps it's better to tell someone
who doubts us that we are going to
achieve a goal and then of course
they're not going to give us the
positive feedback we're not going to get
all that reward circuitry activated
rather we're going to get the uh
friction circuitry activated of us
wanting to prove ourselves and overcome
the uh let's just say the lack of faith
in our ability to achieve a goal and
indeed that can work there is evidence
that can work but then of course you
have to find someone who doesn't believe
in you you have to get them to tell you
they don't believe in you and that could
have all sorts of delerious
psychological effects that might
undermine the goal Pursuit process and
other things as well so if you are lucky
enough to know somebody who doubts you
go ahead tell them that you want to
pursue your specific priority goal but
more likely than not the best thing to
do is to Simply keep that goal to
yourself you may need to inform a family
member or others of you know where you
will be between the hours of say 8:00
a.m. and 9:00 a.m. if you're going to be
exercising or learning language or
meditating whatever it is during that
period of time but what I'm referring to
here is what I will call the don't tell
the world rule don't tell the world that
you're going to achieve X Y or Z just
simply tell yourself in fact I would
suggest that the more time you can spend
with that one or two or three sheets of
paper where you defined the goal the
specific actions that you're going to
take how you're going to measure
progress which we'll talk about bit more
later the more time that you can spend
with that goal in your mind and on that
paper the higher the probability that
you will achieve that goal that stands
in start contrast to telling everyone
around you that you're going to achieve
a certain goal the so-called
accountability myth or the myth of
accountability within the context of
goal Pursuit would be the more specific
way uh to describe that myth now it
turns out there is some utility to
having one person that is a so-called
accountability buddy if that person is
really just L addressing accountability
they are reminding you to do what you
need to do or they are asking you did
you do what you said you were going to
do but that's a bit more of a tough love
accountability model what the don't tell
the world rule is really about is not
getting the kind of dopamine and other
forms of neurochemical reward that come
from just simply saying that you're
going to pursue a goal because as you'll
soon learn that dopamine and other
molecules too of course are going to be
critically important not just for
initiating the sorts of actions re IR
ired to achieve your goals but for
re-engaging and constantly updating your
strategy to ensure that you reach your
goals it's worth mentioning that the
friction model of achieving your goals
does work I mean I for instance am
somebody that if you know I were to say
to a family member or friend hey I'm
going to achieve a particular goal and
they said no there's no way you can do
it that would recruit a certain set of
neural circuits and uh hormones and
neurochemicals in me that would make me
much more likely to lean into the
required set of efforts to achieve that
goal but there's a danger in approaching
a given goal that way especially if the
goal is something that you already want
to pursue which is that then a lot of
your effort becomes framed in the
context of making someone else wrong as
opposed to achieving the goal and of
course you can do two things in parallel
you can achieve your goal and prove
somebody else wrong but as we've talked
about in various episodes on motivation
and pursuit and the dopamine system and
as we'll talk about a bit more in a few
minutes the there something tremendously
powerful about learning how to derive
pleasure from the effort process itself
that is learning to enjoy the process of
pursuing a goal for sake of that goal
for yourself rather than trying to
pursue a goal simply to prove somebody
else wrong I'll just tell you right now
that intrinsic motivation motivation
that is directly attached to the thing
that you are doing and root to a goal is
the most powerful and sustainable source
of motivation
as many of you know I've been taking ag1
daily since 2012 so I'm delighted that
they're sponsoring the podcast ag1 is a
vitamin mineral probiotic drink that's
designed to meet all of your
foundational nutrition needs now of
course I try to get enough servings of
vitamins and minerals through whole food
sources that include vegetables and
fruits every day but often times I
simply can't get enough servings but
with ag1 I'm sure to get enough vitamins
and minerals and the probiotics that I
need and it also contains adaptogens to
help buffer stress simply put always
feel better when I take ag1 I have more
focus and energy and I sleep better and
it also happens to taste great for all
these reasons whenever I'm asked if you
could take Just One supplement what
would it be I answer ag1 if you'd like
to try ag1 go to drink a1.com huberman
to claim a special offer they'll give
you five free travel packs plus a year
supply of vitamin D3 K2 again that's
drink a1.com
huberman the final protocol related to
goal setting because because really up
until now we've been talking only about
goal setting we haven't yet talked about
goal Pursuit is that you want your goal
to be measurable and when we say
measurable you really have to Define two
things first of all you are going to
have to Define how long you are going to
pursue this goal overall in other words
how long you think it will take before
you achieve your goal and in addition to
that you are going to have to Define how
much time you are going to spend
pursuing that goal each week or each day
now there are an infinite number of time
blocks that one could use to answer
these questions so for instance you
could set an overall yearly goal and you
could break it down into monthly goals
where you spend x amount of time on that
goal each week and x amount of time on
that goal each day and essentially
ladder up from the shortest time frame
to the longest time frame required to
achieve that goal and certainly all of
that is doable but that I believe is
going to be an overwhelming amount of
work and indeed is going to be
counterproductive toward achieving your
goal what I recommend which of course is
gleaned from the scientific literature
at least the consistencies or the center
of mass that is the major findings that
show up again and again in the
scientific literature on goal setting a
Pursuit is that you establish a roughly
12 week period of time to focus on your
specific goal now of course achieving
the entire goal might take longer than
12 weeks but chances are it's not going
to take shorter than 12 weeks although
if it does you could simply close out
that goal Pursuit and then pursue
another goal there's no reason you
couldn't do that but there's nothing
magical about this 12-week period but it
seems to adhere to a number of things in
society and culture in work schedules in
seasonality meaning the holidays and the
shifts in the overall Seasons that works
for most goals and most people so a
12-week cycle or roughly a thre month
cycle sometimes called the quarterly
cycle of goal Pursuit toward your
particular goal I think is a good macro
time to focus on and then within that
12we cycle to Define very clearly how
many hours each week and each day and on
which days you will pursue that goal
okay so it's 12-week cycle to pursue
your goal that goal might be achieved by
the end of that 12 weeks or even prior
it might not be but you said a 12we
cycle or quarterly cycle or if you
prefer to think about it a 3 month cycle
and then you define how many hours per
week you are going to spend pursuing
that goal and then you define how many
hours per day you are going to spend
pursuing that goal and then you define
which days of the week you are going to
pursue that particular goal I think
those three numbers the 12-week
quarterly AKA 3-mth cycle the number of
hours per week and the number of hours
per day and particular days that you're
going to spend working on a goal is
going to be effective for 90% if not
more of different types of goals out
there and as with defining the specific
goal itself I highly recommend that you
write this down with a pen or pencil
there's just oh so much data to support
the fact that writing things down
ideally in complete sentences on a piece
of paper with a pen or pencil serves to
reinforce the goal setting and pursuit
process greatly increasing the
probability that you will achieve those
goals so what you're really defining in
that process are the specific verb
action that you are going to take and
the specific quantifiable amount of time
that you are engaging in those verb
actions in order to achieve your goal
what we haven't discussed yet however is
how to define or quantify the goal
itself now of course in different
Endeavors you're going to have the
opportunity to quantify and Define goal
achievement in different ways so for
instance if you want to be able to run a
sub six-minute mile or a sub five minute
mile
or if you're really impressive a sub
four minute mile well that's a highly
quantifiable goal that you can break
down into a series of training steps or
Milestones meaning that you could
quantify at the beginning of your goal
Pursuit how long it takes you to run a
mile you could then set out to achieve a
faster time within two weeks or three
weeks and then do the appropriate
training to achieve those numbers and
simply keep updating that in order to
eventually reach your quantifiable goal
at 12 weeks again you might not complete
your goal of running a sub five minute
mile or sub six minute mile at the end
of 12 weeks but perhaps if your goal is
to be able to run a sub five minute mile
by the end of the calendar year and
you're initiating this whole goal
Pursuit thing on the first of the year
well then you have 12 months broken into
four 3month cycles and you would
essentially set the quantifiable goal at
the end of the year December 31st
perhaps is when you actually do that run
um where you hopefully would achieve
that sub 6 minute or 5 minute mile or
maybe even 4 minute mile and then you
backtrack from that date and you set
Milestones of goals that you're trying
to achieve that's a highly quantifiable
set of goals because it is literally
distance Over time however in a lot of
Pursuits in fact I would argue in most
Pursuits you don't have that very clear
quantifiable result you might have for
instance the achievement of a doctoral
degree or a bachelor's degree or an AA
degree or a professional degree of some
sort which represents a Finish Line um
you could perhaps even attach a gray
point average or a publication goal to
that but in most Endeavors that aren't
athletic or aren't within the realm of
Finance it becomes much harder to very
clearly Define your goal in purely
quantitative terms so that is the reason
why we spent so much time talking about
the measurability of the specific amount
of time that you're going to engage in
the verb actions that each day which
days each week over the course of these
12we Cycles because ultimately what's
going to allow you to arrive at
successful achievement of your goal
regardless of whether or not that goal
is highly quantifiable X number of
dollars X number of minutes to complete
a mile run or Swim
Etc or it's something that's a bit more
nebulous in terms of quantifiability
like conversational French right there's
conversational French that you can learn
there's also conversational French that
incorporates humor or that incorporates
Good Humor or um perhaps you want to get
better at writing poetry or simply spend
time writing poetry can you quantify the
quality of that poetry well perhaps uh
you know if you could win a particular
prize for poetry but I think for most
Endeavors they are more Loosely defined
in terms of their quantifiability now we
can always attach quantifiability to the
ultimate end goal if we choose so for
instance
I could decide that I'm going to learn
conversational French and I could decide
that the ultimate goal at the end of
this 12we period is to be able to have a
10-minute conversation with somebody who
is fluent in French they're native born
in France and that I'm going to make
zero mistakes that's a pretty lofty goal
but the point being that if you are
picking a goal that is not easily
quantifiable you want to be
exceptionally precise about the amount
of time that you are going to spend in
engaging in the specific verb actions
that are going to allow you to make
progress toward your goal because
ultimately whether or not it's a highly
quantifiable goal or it's a more Loosely
quantifiable goal in terms of the end
goal the process of achieving goals is
always going to be in the form of
actions and actions themselves are
always quantifiable it's number of hours
of dedicated work toward that particular
goal a common example of an end goal
that's very hard to quantify in terms of
the end goal itself is the writing of a
book book for instance now you could set
out to write an 800 page book but most
people agree that the length of the book
should have something more or less to do
with the content and not the other way
around in other words that you don't
just want to add words in order to
achieve a certain number of pages that
said most all experienced writers will
tell you at least two things they'll
tell you first don't wait for
inspiration simply set a period of time
each day that you're going to write and
write X number of words or for x amount
of time each each day or perhaps even
just three days a week but most of the
experienced writers that I've spoken to
write every single day and they write
800 words per day or 2,000 words per day
or 500 words per day whatever they can
do consistently they may do it for time
they may do it for words but they are
writing during that time they are not
waiting for inspiration to land on them
they're not trying to get optimally
caffeinated and perhaps they didn't even
sleep that well the night before in
other words they are dedicated to
engaging in a particular number of hours
of word generating action rather than
trying to focus on getting the number
one best seller at the end after the
book is published of course they can
wish for that number one position on the
bestseller chart But ultimately the
greatest probability of achieving that
goal is going to come from engaging in a
particular number of hours generating a
particular number of words each day so
again the highest probability of
achieving our goals of achieving any
kind of goal is going to be by
understanding the specific verb actions
that we need to engage in and then
quantifying the amount of time that we
engage in those specific word actions
and then simply doing those verbs so up
until now we've been talking about goal
setting and we really haven't talked
about goal Pursuit itself so now I'd
like to talk about what the scientific
literature says is the best protocol for
initiating our goal Pursuit for starting
toward our goal and to do so we have to
address a set of key questions the
questions you have to ask yourself are
do I do I want to pursue this goal
meaning am I highly motivated to pursue
this goal or even mildly motivated to
pursue this goal do I want to do the
things involved to get this thing to
accomplish this thing or am I feeling
resistance do I not want to pursue this
goal or perhaps this is a daytoday shift
that occurs where some days you're
really motivated and other days you are
not now the reason to ask yourself the
set of questions is that the data say
that there are two different strategies
in fact two markedly different
strategies that you'll want to
incorporate depending on whether or not
you're motivated or you are unmotivated
to pursue that particular goal for
whatever reason and of course there's an
entire psychology to motivation and you
could get a therapist or a coach to work
with in order to address that underlying
psychology yes it might ladder back to
Childhood issues it might ladder back to
esteem things none of that can be
covered here in any sort of meaningful
depth because frankly we each have
different circumstances different pasts
different psychologies there are however
some universals that we can all apply in
order to help us get started toward our
goal and this is nested in this whole
concept of whether or not we should
visualize the end and successful
completion of our goal so keep the end
in mind as we start off toward a goal or
whether or not we should incorporate a
different strategy here's how it goes so
if you ask
yourself do I want to achieve this goal
and I would hope the answer is yes
because the overall goal should be
something that you want to pursue it
should be something that you are deeply
Desiring to accomplish then you have to
ask yourself next do I want to do the
things required to achieve that goal now
maybe you don't want to do all of them
you only want to do some of them but
given that you've now carefully
Quantified which specific actions you're
going to be doing on which days and for
how many hours and how many weeks for
these 12we blocks you could simply ask
yourself you do I want to do this thing
today and if the answer is yes well then
it turns out that spending just one to
three maybe five minutes but even just
one minute visualizing the outcome the
positive outcome of course and the
feeling state that you may have because
of course you don't know you don't have
a uh time machine you can't feel
yourself into the future but you can
make a good guess as to how you might
feel in the future if you accomplish
that goal spending one to three maybe
five minutes in a sort of meditation
although sort of a visualiz a is perhaps
the better way to describe it thinking
about that feeling State and the outcome
and some of the things that are going to
be associated with that outcome turns
out to be a great practice to engage in
just prior to initiating that day's work
toward that goal however if you arrive
to your practice meaning you show up to
the piano to learn piano or you're
sitting down to the table or maybe you
haven't even gotten enough motivation to
go toward the piano or toward your
notebook or computer or whatever
landscape it is that you are going to be
uh pursuing your goal with in and you
are having quote unquote a hard time
getting motivated toward that goal well
then it turns out what the scientific
literature tells us is that visualizing
the end keeping the end in mind positive
visualization of all the good things
that you'll experience when you achieve
that goal is not going to be an
effective strategy to motivate you
rather if you are not feeling motivated
then what the scientific literature
tells us is that you actually want to
spend one to three maybe 5 minutes
visualizing failure visualizing how
terrible you will feel if you do not
achieve your goal visualizing severe
consequences perhaps mostly of the sort
like telling yourself gosh I set a goal
I set a 12we block I quantify it I know
I want to do this here I have the time
to do it and I'm simply just not doing
it and in that case you would think okay
well you should kind of build yourself
up maybe call a friend text a friend get
some encouragement no the scientific
literat tells us that when we are not
motivated and it is a goal that we
actually want to pursue and of course
here I'm talking about adaptive goal
Pursuit meaning things that are going to
enrich your mental health physical
health Etc not things that are going to
be detrimental to us well then if you're
not feeling motivated you want to spend
one to three perhaps five minutes
meditating concentrating on what it's
going to feel like to fail and the fact
that you are not succeeding but indeed
that you are failing and I I know this
sounds like rather harsh advice that
this protocol uh sounds like kind of a
self- flatulating protocol it's not
intended to be self flatulation in fact
it should not be self flatulation but
rather what you want to do when you are
not motivated is to think about failure
and what that failure at the end of 12
weeks will feel like and the reason for
that is that the data tell us that when
we visualize positive outcomes yes it
deploys certain neurochemicals in our
brain and body that make us feel good
although frankly if you've heard that
imagining something creates the same
neurochemical and neuros circuit states
in the brain as actually experiencing
that thing that is simply not true
that's a myth we've talked about this in
previous episodes that's simply not true
but if you are having a hard time
getting motivated toward a goal that you
actually want to achieve then spending
that short amount of time thinking about
how lousy you'll feel when you don't
achieve it recruits certain elements of
your so-called autonomic nervous system
it creates shifts in the release of
things like epinephrine norepinephrine
even release of the so-called reward
molecule dopamine which in fact is not
the molecule of reward it is the
molecule of motivation and it's
associated with pain It's associated
with negative thoughts and of course
it's associated with positive thoughts
and outcomes but basically what I'm
saying is if you're highly motivated to
do something you're ready to go spend
one to three minutes maybe five
visualizing the positive outcomes that
you're going to EXP experience when you
ultimately finish out that 12 we cycle
as a consequence of all the great work
that you've done if however you are not
motivated you're feeling like I don't
want to do this thing I'm
procrastinating I'm just not feeling
like doing it yes I want to achieve the
goal but I just don't feel like doing it
well then your task is to take one to
three maybe five minutes and think about
how much more lousy you will feel when
you do not achieve that goal at the end
of 12 weeks and that the data tell us
recruit certain elements of your nervous
system your hormonal system that are
more successful in getting you into
action into starting toward your goal
than were you to try and build yourself
up towards all that positivity so yes
indeed there is a place for negative
thinking I'd like to take a quick break
and acknowledge our sponsor inside
tracker inside tracker is a personalized
nutrition platform that analyzes data
from your blood and DNA to help you
better understand your body and help you
meet your health goals I'm a big
believer in getting regular blood work
done for the simple reason that many of
the factors the impact your immediate
and long-term Health can only be
analyzed from a quality blood test
however with a lot of blood tests out
there you get information back about
blood lipids about hormones and so on
but you don't know what to do with that
information with inside tracker they
have a personalized platform that makes
it very easy to understand your data
that is to understand what those lipids
what those hormone levels etc mean and
behavioral supplement nutrition and
other protocols to adjust those numbers
to bring them into the ranges that are
ideal for your immediate and long-term
Health inside trackers plan now includes
measures of both apob and of insulin
which are key indicators of
cardiovascular health and energy
regulation if you'd like to try insid
tracker you can visit insid tracker.com
huberman to get 20% off any of insid
tracker's plans again that's insid
tracker.com huberman to get 20% off now
in terms of tools or protocols to both
initiate and to sustain effort during
your goal Pursuit process we need to
think about the specific time domain or
the amount of time that we're trying to
do that within so for instance there are
tools that you can use to stay motivated
within the 1hour learning block that you
happen to be doing on Monday morning for
instance and there are other tools and
protocols that you can incorporate
towards staying motivated from one day
to the next or from one week to the next
but I think the most useful of those
tools are going to be the tools that you
incorporate to stay motivated within a
given training block or practice block
toward your goal because what I just
described a few minutes ago was the
process of how to initiate your daily
work right you ask yourself that
question am I motivated the answer could
be yes could be no if you really want to
get you know uh quantitative about it
you could give yourself a 1 to 10 score
10 being the most motivated frankly I'm
not that quantitative about that sort of
thing I'm more subjective about it but I
know some of you are real um number
junkies and you really like to quantify
everything keep a journal and look back
see how that relates to your sleep you
know some people are of that orientation
other people like myself are simply
going to you know sit down and say okay
it's time it's time to train or it's
time to practice whatever the thing may
be how motivated am I am I a I don't
know like a six out of 10 or a seven out
of 10 okay I'm ready to go I'm going to
visualize the end in mind in a positive
way or if I'm a two out of 10 or
anything less than a four out of 10 I'm
thinking I'm not that motivated so then
I'm going to basically scare myself into
doing the work that day so that's how
you initiate the work each day and I
just gave you a couple of quick examples
of how you could quantify that took me
about 30 seconds to do that example out
loud take you about 30 seconds to do but
again if you want to quantify it in more
detail and write it down and relate it
to other things be my guest so now you
already have a science based protocol
for how to get started each day toward
your goal now what about within the one
or twoh hour block or perhaps 90-minute
block that you're going to use to pursue
your goal and here it's very important
that you have a number of tools that
will allow you to both set the optimal
amount of focus so that you're really
concentrating on pursuing that goal
you're concentrated on the verb actions
that will deliver you to that goal is
perhaps the best way to state that and
that you can constantly update or renew
your level of focus should it start to
dissipate now I want to be clear I've
done entire episodes about focus and how
to increase focus with behavioral tools
everything related to meditation which
indeed can increase your ability to
focus I've talked about nutritional
tools supplementation tools prescription
drug related tools there's a lot of
information on that you can simply go to
hubman lab.com put focus into the search
function and it will take you to not
only those episodes and the toolkit for
that but the specific timestamps for
that but what we are going to talk about
now is not about how to increase Focus
per se rather it's about how to use
focus in particular visual focus in
order to increase your or maintain your
level of motivation within a given
learning block within a given batch of
time on a given day where you are
pursuing your goal you're engaging in
that practice which of course will
include frustration anxiety it has to if
you're going to get any better and how
to set that motivation and keep that
motivation throughout that hour or 90
minutes or two hours is critical so how
do you do that well it turns out it's
fairly straightforward so it's anchored
in the fact that your cognitive Focus
your ability to maintain a narrow cone
of attention as well as your bodily
state of Readiness and your mental state
of Readiness to perform work is
powerfully anchored to your visual
system as many of you have heard me say
before your eyes are actually two pieces
of brain I mean to be more specific the
neural retinas that line the back of
your eyes like py crust are literally
two pieces of your central nervous
system of your brain that were extruded
from the cranial Vault during
development so yes these two bits and
for those listening I'm just pointing to
my eyes your eyes are two pieces of
brain outside of your skull and your
eyes can view things broadly so so you
can uh so-called soften your gaze and
view the entire Horizon you can see the
periphery of the room by relaxing your
eyes you can actually do this now in
fact when you drive most of the time
you're doing this you're not looking at
a particular focal point you're viewing
things in so-call panoramic vision and
of course you can draw your visual Focus
to a particular location what we call a
virgin eye movement that is you're
bringing your eyes in toward the center
toward your nose a little bit and you're
focusing them in a more narrow cone of
visual attention this is something you
can do almost imperceptibly to others
although if we were to measure your eye
movements what we would see is that your
eyes are actually moving inward a little
bit toward your nose when you do this
virgin eye movement and narrowing that
cone of visual attention and then
they're you relaxing into a state of um
being slightly further out from your
nose not the eyes themselves of course
they can't move within the sockets but
you know the pupils of your eyes are
moving out a bit from your nose and
you're in so-called panoramic Vision so
essentially what I'm saying is that you
can narrow or broaden your visual
attention and that's something that can
take a little bit of practice I highly
recommend that you try this and that you
practice it a little bit but indeed
everyone has the neural Machinery to do
this from birth this is not something
that requires neuroplasticity to be able
to do you can do this right now you can
narrow your visual attention you can
expand or relax your visual attention
and thereby narrow or relax your visual
field from being smaller or larger there
are data that show that when we narrow
our visual attention and we hold that
narrow visual tension on a spot several
things happen first of all there's
recruitment of circuitry within the
so-called brain stem that then deploys
neurochemicals that increase our level
of alertness and arousal that's right
when you focus your visual attension on
a more narrow location or one location
in front of you and you hold that
Focus you are causing the release of
neurochemicals that increase your
overall level of alertness in the brain
brain and body conversely when you relax
your visual Focus so-called panoramic
Vision you are turning off that
recruitment you're not actively
recruiting molecules for relaxation
within the brain but you are turning off
this release of the neurochemicals
associated with increasing focus and
arousal so why am I talking about this
in the context of goal Pursuit well if
you are feeling lack of motivation at
any point within a given training block
or bism calling it this could be at the
beginning this could be 5 minutes in
this could be half an hour in you would
be wise to pick a visual Target ideally
a visual Target that is within the
general range of the work that you're
trying to perform in other words if
you're doing desk work with a piece of
paper you would draw that visual Target
on a piece of paper approximately the
same distance that you were reading or
that you were looking at music um you
can tell how little uh playing of piano
I've done in my life but the point being
that you set the visual Target at a
approximately the same distance that you
would be performing your particular work
so if you're doing a sport the distance
might be some many meters off in the
distance whereas if you're doing desk
work of some kind then it might be much
closer and then you focus your eyes on
that location and you actively work to
maintain that Focus just like I'm doing
now into the camera for a given period
of time and I recommend that you set a
timer and that you of course allow
yourself to Blink like I just did there
and that you try and Achieve at least 30
seconds but even better would be 60
seconds even better would be 90 seconds
of that Focus virgin eye movement during
which several things happen including
the deployment of those neurochemicals
from the brain stem that I talked about
before which are going to increase your
level of autonomic arousal and also
increase your level of focus further and
there I'm not just talking about visual
Focus I'm talking about cognitive focus
it has also been shown that when we
focus on a particular point in the way
that I'm describing here that it
increases our so-called systolic blood
pressure as many of you know blood
pressure is always described to us as a
given number over another number and the
first number is the so-called systo or
systolic pressure which is the amount of
pressure your vascular system when the
heart beats as the fluid of your blood
is pumping through the arteries veins
and capillaries of your system and then
the bottom number is the amount of
pressure within those arteries veins and
capillar iies in between heartbeat so
it's the systolic over the diastolic and
what we know is that visual focus and
here I'm still holding mine now on the
camera so for those of you listening I
probably blinked once or twice but I'm
really trying hard to maintain my focus
directly within the camera this visual
Focus increases the systolic blood
pressure it increases the deployment of
those neurochemicals from the brain stem
and we know it also can recruit The
Liberation of molecules such as dopamine
and some Associated molecules elsewhere
in the brain that together act in a
synergistic way to increase our level of
focus and motivation this is based again
on work describing the neural circuitry
of what I'm describing here and work
from Emily bis's lab which has shown
that if people focus on a Target on a
goal line literally a physical location
within their environment and then they
initiate some work it could be physical
work or cognitive work not only do they
experience significantly decreased
levels of perceived effort while
engaging in that work but they also
complete that work in a significantly
reduced amount of time meaning that
within a given training bout or training
block you are able to get significantly
more work done and you perceive that as
less effortful or requiring less effort
than had you not done this visual Focus
now I've been doing this for quite some
time now into the camera this is
actually a practice that I've been doing
for well over a decade and it's actually
a practice that I use when I podcast or
when I post on social media it's part of
the reason why I'm accused of being a
non- blinker quite often but I want to
remind people that you are allowed to
Blink don't let your eyes dry out it's
perfectly fine to Blink it's not going
to inhibit the effectiveness of this
protocol but I don't think I can really
overstate how valuable this sort of
protocol is first of all it's completely
behavioral it costs nothing it's
completely safe as long as you remember
to Blink and it allows you to increase
your level of focus your level of
motivation and the sustainability of
your focus and motivation while in goal
Pursuit so it's a quite valuable
protocol to incorporate and it's
something that you can do once for 30
seconds and then lean into whatever it
is your writing process your running
process it's something that you could do
repeatedly throughout that learning bout
and it's something that you can practice
offline a little bit away from that
training bout as a means to sort of
learn and get familiar with so that then
you can incorporate it very quickly and
repeatedly and with much more
Effectiveness during these different
learning doubts again it's a highly
valuable tool that's ground grounded in
neural circuitry grounded in
neurochemistry and that Emily bis's lab
has shown in numerous domains physical
Pursuits cognitive Pursuits can really
help people achieve their goals and to
achieve them more easily or at least
with less perceived effort and more
quickly now we can get a bit more
granular about the incorporation of this
tool this protocol but before we do we
should acknowledge that all of the
things that lend themselves to improved
cognitive focus and physical ability
still hold true right you still need to
get good sleep as many nights of your
life as you possibly can you still need
to eat properly you still need to try
and limit your stress we have podcast
episodes related to all of those topics
we have toolkits available at zero cost
related to all of those topics I'm not
saying that this visual Focus or visual
Target Training is the only tool that
you should incorporate it's a tool that
you want to superimpose on the
foundation of all the things that bring
you to your practice with the best
possible cognition the best possible
physical Readiness and that when added
to that Foundation of excellent sleep
excellent nutrition social connection
sunlight in the morning Etc is going to
increase the probability that you're
going to make those learning bouts as
effective as possible now some of you
may be thinking elevating your blood
pressure is bad why would I want to
elevate my blood pressure ah well it
turns out that these increases in
systolic blood pressure achieved with
this visual Target Training or focusing
on a Finish Line for some period of time
are transient and they are perfect ly
safe so essentially what it does is it
boosts or bolsters the activity of the
autonomic nervous system it kickstarts
the deployment of those chemicals and
those neural circuits that then allow
you to be motivated for some period of
time but then that is a transient
increase in autonomic rousel which is
why perhaps every 20 minutes or perhaps
on the hour you might stop do a 30
second or 60-second visual Target
Training and then lean back into your
process of however you it is that you
are pursuing your goal I should also
mention that if your eyes are getting
tired doing whatever goal Pursuit you
happen to be engaged in it's also a good
idea to go into that panoramic Vision
mode the easiest way to do that is to go
outside or to be outside and to view a
horizon and not look at any one
particular point on the horizon but if
you're indoors as I am now you can also
just relax your eyes you know you know
blinking a few times and getting rid of
that virgin's eye movement and try and
visualize the corners of the room or the
sides of the room rather the floor and
the ceiling all at once that's a good
way to expl expl how to so-call relax
your eyes and take you out of that
virgin's eye movement and I say this
because a lot of people will feel when
they're pursuing their goal that it's
kind of fatiguing so you have to
remember to Breathe Right you still want
to breathe as you're pursuing your goal
and you certainly want to be visually
focused on your goal so you're
cognitively focused on your goal and
you're motivated but that from time to
time you also relax take a moment shake
things off look into your panoramic
Vision mode and then go back to your
mode of goal Pursuit now there are a few
other protocols that might seem Oho
simple but frankly are oh so effective
that I'd be remiss if I didn't mention
them the first of those is actually
something that I'm borrowing from Tim
Ferris who did a post on Instagram which
we will link to which I think is just
spectacular which is 30 things that he
wished he had known when he was 20 and
while the internet is choca block full
of such lists that particular list is
truly impressive those are things that I
too wish I had known when I was 20 but
also when I was 30 and 40 and so on but
one particular thing on that list of 30
is particularly relevant now which is
that the best productivity app is
already on your phone which is to put
your phone into airplane mode or more
ideally and this is the one that I try
my best to incorporate to Simply turn
the phone off and remove it from my
workouts or my attempts to learn
language or my attempts to learn
anything I realize that some people need
to keep their phone with them for
reasons related to communicating with
family or uh co-workers Etc that's fine
if you need your phone but to the extent
that you can remove yourself from
distractions that's certainly going to
en enhance your ability to focus on what
you need to focus on in pursuing your
goals that sort of stands without saying
it's kind of a duh and yet I think a lot
of people are searching far and wide for
the productivity app for the secret hack
for the thing that's going to allow them
to be Pro productive and oftentimes
there are DOs actions that we can take
in order to become more productive we're
talking about some of those today we've
talked about those in other episodes but
there are of course important don't so
don't have your phone facing up with
Wi-Fi and Celler service on if you want
to be productive at something that
doesn't evolve your phone ideally you'll
turn it over you'll turn it off you'll
get rid of it you'll put it in the Next
Room if you're like me you'll sometimes
lock it in the car I think the most
extreme that I've ever gone to ensure
that I didn't um engage with my phone
during goal Pursuit was during the early
days of having my laboratory and I was
writing multiple grants in parallel
which is an immense amount of work I
would walk into the lab labatory in the
morning and I would hand a student or
postto my phone and I'd say don't give
this back to me until 5:00 p.m. and if I
ask for it back if I even ask for it
once everyone in the lab gets
$500 there were quite a few people in my
lab and so it's a significant cost to
that and I must tell you there were
numerous times throughout the day when I
impulsively just thought okay I'm going
need my phone damn it I don't want to
have to do it and I also wanted to
demonstrate to them that I could create
an incentive system whereby I could
basically Scruff myself into getting the
work done and indeed um much to their
dismay I never once had to pay them out
although when we got the grants and
indeed even when we didn't get the
grants I did take them all to dinner now
another key protocol for maintaining
motivation while pursuing your goals
stems from our understanding of the
dopamine reward and motivation Pathways
topics for which I have done multiple
indeed three podcast episodes previously
and we can provide a link to all three
of those as well as the toolkit that
we've published and that's available to
you at zero cost on our website about
how to regulate dopamine both Baseline
dopamine stores and peaks in dopamine
there's a lot there to be understood and
Incorporated because it has to do with
various things not just in the realm of
goal Pursuit but also feelings of
well-being um staving off depression
things of that sort the dopamine system
is linked to oh so many important
aspects of Life far too many than we
could discuss right now and we have
those previous episodes in which we do
discuss all of that material nonetheless
it is important to understand that
dopamine is the molecule of motivation
and to some extent reward but really
motivation and that if you want to
maintain consistent motivation during
say your individual bouts of work toward
your goals and from one bout to the next
so not just within a session but from
day to day across sessions and from week
to week and indeed from 12we cycle to
12we cycle if that's required and from
one goal that you set to the next goal
that you define and decide to pursue you
want to understand this particular
feature of dopamine which is that yes
dopamine and its release is highly
valuable toward getting more motivated
and feeling more motivated but that it
has certain properties related to things
like dopamine reward prediction error
baselines of dopamine
Etc that make it the case that if you
reward yourself every time you reach a
milestone say you finish out an hour or
two hours of work so you treat yourself
to something you reward yourself that
you are going to diminish both the
potency of that reward and you are going
to reduce your motivation over time that
might be surprising to you but if you
were to watch those episodes it would
all become clear as to why that is the
case it is also true that if you were to
only reward yourself when you accomplish
your goal or perhaps more commonly if
you look at the accomplishment of your
goal as the only reward in the whole
process of goal Pursuit and achievement
that is going to undermine your
probability of success as well rather
the best way to incorporate the
mechanics of the dopamine system such
that you can achieve not just immediate
motivation but ongoing motivation is to
incorporate what is referred to as
random intermittent reinforcement which
is what the casinos use to keep people
playing it simply
means randomly reward yourself and
randomly don't reward yourself for
successful completion of Milestones
those Milestones could be within a bout
of effort or it could be across bouts of
effort so let's say you set out at the
beginning on your piece of paper to
basically let's say run or practice at
some cognitive Endeavor four hours total
per week and you're going to do that
Monday Wednesday Friday and Saturday
should you reward yourself at the end of
each session should you reward yourself
at the end of each week the answer is it
depends and it should depend in a random
intermittent way so the simplest way to
do this is whenever you complete a
milestone could be at the end of a day
you did your one hour whatever it was
that you designated you were going to do
on that particular day should you reward
yourself cognitively or with some
physical thing I don't know what that
physical thing might be but it I don't
know could be a meal could be a movie
could be something that you enjoy well
the answer is you should flip a coin and
if it's heads yes reward yourself and if
it's Tails don't it's that simple it is
that simple it should be 50/50
probability and it's random as to
whether or not you reward yourself now
with physical rewards like monetary
Rewards or food rewards or a movie or
participating in something else that you
enjoy it's a bit easier to define the
cognitive rewarding of One's Own efforts
is something that people really struggle
to comprehend but what I'm not referring
to when I say cognitive rewards is I'm
not referring to saying yes I'm the best
and really trying to shower yourself
with internal praise and tell yourself
that you're the greatest thing that ever
happened simply because you performed
this learning bout what I'm simply
referring to is the kind of
internal dopamine reward that comes from
telling yourself like yes I'm making
progress I'm making progress I'm on the
path I'm able to set a goal and achieve
a goal which might seem like a healthy
thing to do psychologically and in fact
it is it's great I think it's really
important that people be able to
self-reward themselves especially
self-reward for verbs that put them in a
more adaptive stance in life that
enhance their mental health physical
health and performance and that of
course also includes relationships we're
not just talking about solitary Pursuits
here we're talking about Pursuits that
bring us into the world that allow us to
lean into life with more Vigor and with
more Effectiveness not just to help
ourselves but to help others so what I'm
referring to is completing something and
internally patting yourself on the back
for having completed that thing thing
that is a good thing to do but if you
want to maintain ongoing motivation
you're not going to do that every time
you're not going to punish yourself but
rather you finish out a bout of learning
you flip the coin let's say it lands
tails on that day you simply shift into
the next thing you need to do that day
now it is not easy to suppress thoughts
we know this it's very hard to suppress
negative thoughts but it's still hard to
suppress positive thoughts so internally
if you're glowing from the fact that you
performed well don't try and suppress
that that's okay but if you flip a Tails
then you don't want to actively engage
in a self-reward process however if you
flip the coin and it's heads well then
you should absolutely engage in a
self-reward process and that process
should consist of 30 to 60 seconds of
closing your eyes well you don't have to
it works better if you close your eyes
and simply thinking about the fact that
yes you can set a goal you can engage in
the specific set of questions do I want
to do this practice today do I not want
to do this practice today and then the
specific set of actions maybe they
involve visual focus and the other tools
we talked about turning off of your
phone Etc and you are somebody who can
get things done you are somebody that is
moving forward toward your particular
goal and so you just sort of create a
little bit of a positive cognitive loop
around that ability that you are in fact
building up and that's something that
people often Overlook which is that not
only is moving toward a goal great
because it establishes more robustness
in the neural circuits that allow us to
perform that thing right I mean after
all that's what learning is eventually
you don't achieve the same frustration
and errors that you do when trying to
perform that thing eventually you learn
how to play the piano you learn how to
speak conversational French you run that
sub six-minute mile but also the neural
circuits associated with self-generated
motivation and with the tools that we're
talking about themselves are subject to
neuroplasticity so those become more
robust and that's fantastic because when
you eventually reach one goal I would
hope that you would then update and set
out to achieve another goal and you will
find that over time you will be more
effective in achieving other goals by
virtue of the work that you did in
pursuing a previous goal because
ultimately it's really about defining
goals and then learning how to quantify
the actions required and then engaging
in those actions so there's the specific
circuits involved in generating those
actions which are very goal specific and
then there are the circuits which
circuits are we talking about we're
talking about that amydala the lateral
prefrontal cortex the orbital frontal
cortex and the basil ganglia we talked
about earlier that have been built up
that have been reinforced because as I
mentioned there is one universal circuit
for goal Pursuit and achievement So
Random intermittent reinforcement is the
key and while I spent a good amount of
time talking about self-generated
cognitive reinforcement this also
applies to any kind of physical rewards
the movie that you're going to reward
yourself with the ice cream cone the
whatever that you're going to reward
yourself with perhaps it's monetary
perhaps it's food perhaps it's social
random intermittent rewards are the ones
that are going to keep you motivated and
are going to best increase the
probability of success not just within a
given bout of learning not just dayto
day not just week to week not just
quarter to quarter but across the
lifetime an important protocol to
incorporate in your goal Pursuits is one
that I learned from Dr Maya Shankar when
she was a guest on the huban Lab podcast
and she talked about the so-called
middle problem the middle problem is the
fact that people tend to have a lot of
motivation at the outset of pursuing a
goal although you now know that
sometimes or some people don't have a
lot of motivation when pursuing their
goal at the start so they need to think
about failures and how terrible
everything will be and then they will
certainly have motivation it's going to
be a fear-based motivation but in
general people tend to have more
motivation at the start of pursuing a
goal and at the end when they get close
to or they start start to perceive the
finish line but that most people
experience the so-called middle problem
where in the middle of a learning bout
or in the middle of the week or in the
middle of a 12-week cycle they are less
motivated and this has actually been
Quantified in numerous studies and there
are several ways to overcome the middle
problem the simplest one is to
acknowledge it to recognize that it's
coming and so when it does come and
you're experiencing lower levels of
motivation perhaps
even increased failure rates and you're
not performing as well you're getting
frustrated to know that that's a natural
process that everybody experiences and
just knowing that can sometimes allow
people to move through that to the place
where then they can sense the end of the
learning bout or they can sense that
they're making some progress the finish
line is there and then they get that
increase in motivation again however
sometimes the middle problem is such a
problem that people need some tools to
move through it and and the best way to
move through the middle problem or in
fact to eliminate it is actually to make
the middle of a learning bout its own
separate thing that you acknowledge the
presence of and that you break up into
three separate bouts so here we're
talking about carving up the 1 hour
learning bout or the two-hour learning
bout into an initial phase where you
either have naturally occurring
motivation or you use fear-based
visualization to increase your
motivation you lean into that and then
let's assume it's a 1H hour learning
bout and then at about the 25 minute
Mark you start to experience lower
levels of focus perhaps then you use the
visual Target protocol but then you go
back into your bout of learning and
you're not feeling very motivated it's
hard your mind is drifting you want to
pick up your phone you want to do other
things you find yourself doing other
things that's the period of time to take
Say the 25 minute to 45 minute period
within the session and divide it into
perhaps three or even four smaller
chunks of time and you perhaps have
heard of chunking before chunking is
simply breaking something down into
smaller chunks that are more achievable
that's simply what we're talking about
here but really chunking up that middle
section of a learning bout can be very
effective at essentially eliminating the
middle problem now for those of you that
are going to be really nitpicky you'll
say wait you take that 20 minutes from
the 25 minute Mark to the 45 minute Mark
within your hour learning bout and you
divide it up into four little uh chunks
and in those two middle chunks I'm going
to feel the middle problem for those two
middle chunks ah well that's not not
actually the way it pans out fortunately
when you break things down into small
enough chunks you eliminate the middle
problem and you experience sustained
motivation now the extreme
interpretation of that would have you
measuring every minute or even every
second of a learning bout and having
consistent motivation throughout that
because for instance if you can
concentrate for 10 seconds why wouldn't
you simply be able to just mark off
10-second increments well at some point
the marking off or the monitoring of
those increments is going to be
distracting to toward the thing that you
actually want to do so the simple thing
to do is to acknowledge the middle
problem right the fact that we have more
motivation at the start and at the end
of our goal Pursuit sessions than we do
within the middle and then to Simply
chunk that middle section into three
maybe four smaller chunks and if you
need to incorporate things like the
visual Target protocol one or three or
perhaps even eight times within that
middle section so be it it's going to
help you move through with better focus
and better motivation and what I just
described can of course be applied to
the longer bouts of effort that don't
occur just during one learning bout but
perhaps across the week so for instance
if you are doing four days a week of
language learning or Fitness training so
maybe it's a Monday Wednesday Friday
Saturday type of Schedule H you may
notice that in the middle of the week
the Wednesday training session tends to
be the one that you're less motivated to
do for whatever reason there could be
any reason at all for which the
motivation is lower in the middle of the
week it doesn't matter well in that case
you would want to First acknowledge the
presence of the middle problem so you
would want to acknowledge that that
Wednesday training bout is prone to the
middle problem because it is indeed the
middle problem it's in the middle of the
Monday and the Friday training bouts so
then you would want to approach it with
the understanding that it's going to be
there and that you are going to need
tools and protocols that will allow you
to overcome it by for instance taking
that one or two hour session on
Wednesdays and putting a bit more time
toward a visual Target protocol at the
beginning to increase your focus a bit
more more visualizing failure if you are
feeling amotivated that means not
motivated in nerd speak amotivated
toward doing that Wednesday session and
you would want to break up that
Wednesday session into smaller chunks so
instead of looking at that 2hour session
you might break it up into a series of
15 minute smaller learning bouts done
consecutively back toback and then in
doing so you have essentially taken that
Wednesday session and I'll bet that it
becomes at least among your most
motivated sessions so the middle problem
exists it's important to acknowledge and
there are tools to overcome the middle
problem on any time scale you simply
have to Chunk Up the middle and approach
things with deliberate increased Vigor
just as you would you know if you're
running and there's always a tough Hill
you have to really or gear up for
attacking that hill and then to do that
repeatedly in those smaller chunks until
you've completed that session so today
I've been talking about how to approach
goal setting and pursuit at and in
around the specific times that one is
engaged in goal setting and pursuit the
writing down of goals defining of goals
the timing and then the actual training
sessions or the practice sessions toward
achieving that goal what I haven't
talked about is how to show up to all of
that in the best possible State of Mind
and Body in order to achieve the best
possible results and of course there are
numerous things that we need to do in
order to quote unquote show up at our
best where we would stand the best
possibility of Performing our best and
learning the best in those learning
bouts things like getting adequate sleep
getting sunlight in our eyes early in
the day adequate and proper nutrition
social connection and so on we talked
about all of that on previous podcast
episodes so I'm not going to talk about
those again now but it is important to
recognize that the backdrop of Our Lives
how well we've slept what's going on in
our personal lives will all Impact
things like motivation and frankly our
ability to even identify what's
important because you know if we're
dealing with a Health crisis or someone
close to us is dealing with a Health
crisis we tend to have our attention
diverted toward that but I do want to
acknowledge all of that because it is
critically important in defining how
you're going to show up to these
Endeavors and for that matter all
Endeavors now with that said there are a
few things that you can do in order to
try and optimize your ability to focus
and your level of motivation during your
goal Pursuits and there are some really
interesting data and protocols that I
haven't talked so much about on this
podcast ever that are relevant to
today's discussion and this relates to
our so-called circadian rhythms in
attention we have robust rhythms in our
ability to focus and our level of
motivation that vary across the 24-hour
AKA circadian cycle with a regular
rhythmicity that is independent of how
badly we want a goal or how afraid we
are of failure right all the stuff about
motivation and fear of failure and
desire Etc all of that is still true but
we all have a naturally occurring rhythm
of rise and fall and return to rise and
fall of our levels of attention and
motivation and this is something that's
been described beautifully in the
scientific literature in fact I'll
provide a link to what I consider a
really nice review on this topic this is
a review that was published by Pablo
Valdes in the Yale Journal biology and
Medicine in 2019 entitled circadian
rhythms in attention and there's a lot
of information within this review but we
can distill out of a couple of useful
gems from it so if you are somebody who
is embarking on the pursuit of a goal
which is particularly hard that's going
to require a really high level of
motivation and focus know that there are
three times during the day when you
stand to have the greatest level of
focus and attention and of course this
will vary depending on when you went to
sleep at night and when you wake up
there's natural variation in circadian
rhythms but it's worth knowing that most
people find that their level of
attention and motivation is going to be
highest 30 minutes 3 hours and 11 hours
after waking up okay so 30 minutes 3
hours and 11 hours after waking up and
this relates to a number of important
biological principles related to
circadian shifts in body temperature
which are also related to circadian
shifts that means changes around the
24-hour cycle in the release of
particular neurochemicals so the amount
of dopamine available to be released by
any sort of goal pursuit or reward the
amount of Serotonin available lots of
neurochemistry in there lots of neural
circuitry but these heighten levels of
focus and motivation that just occur
naturally regardless of what goal one is
trying to pursue in fact regardless of
whether or not you're trying to pursue
any goal 30 minutes 3 hours and 11 hours
after waking your focus and motivation
are going to be their greatest relative
to other times in that 24-hour cycle now
as I tell you this I can imagine that
some of you are thinking great I'm going
to schedule one bout of goal Pursuits 3
hours after waking and another one 11
hours after waking great if you can do
that and that fits with your work and
other demands of Life your relationships
Etc terrific however I don't want this
30 minute 3-hour and 11-hour protocol to
be considered a rule and here's why most
people don't have a tremendous degree of
control over their schedule things like
work and family and other demands
constrain them in terms of when they can
get the work in and while I do think
it's extremely valuable to schedule the
specific time or roughly the specific
time even though know that's an oxymoron
meaning a period of time during the day
say before 9:00 a.m. or between 9:00 and
noon that you are going to carry out
your goal Pursuit Endeavors I've talked
about this in previous podcasts some
people do very well by scheduling an
exact time from noon to 2 I'm writing
other people like myself do a little
better if I set a constraint but it's a
little bit broader such as I'm going to
exercise before 9 a.m. that could be
anytime before 9:00 a.m. or I'm going to
engage in language learning some time
between say 6:00 p.m. and 9:00 p.m. as
opposed to setting a specific time
that's just what works best for me
people vary in terms of whether or not
they respond best to setting a specific
time or a Time block and setting up
these kind of barriers after which you
are essentially telling yourself you
won't do it but and this is a very
important
but it is most important that you
actually engage in the goal Pursuit and
I experienced this recently I'm trying
to run more these days uh I still enjoy
doing resistance training I still run
three days a week but I'm trying to run
a little bit longer as opposed to just
doing the one long run per week and then
two shorter runs later in the week I've
talked about this in my optimal Fitness
protocol episode if you want to check
that out or check out the PDF where it's
all distilled down to one or two pages
if you like but in any event these days
I'm trying to extend the amount of time
that I'm running I'm just enjoying that
it's kind of a throwback for me to when
I ran across country as a senior in high
school and this was the time of year
when I would start getting ready for the
fall season so I'm enjoying running more
and just this last week I had the
experience of having a very full Sunday
and that's usually the day when I run in
the morning or hike during the middle of
the day and I simply did not get around
to it because I had a lot of other
important things to do and what I found
was 9 p.m. rolled around 10 p.m. rolled
around and I started thinking ah like I
wish I had gone running my Monday was
going to be busy so what did I do I
laced up my shoes and I went for a run
at 1000 p.m. something I haven't done
since college or maybe even high school
and I ended up running for 90 minutes
from 10: p.m. until 11:30 p.m.
definitely not the optimal time for me
to go running in fact I was thinking oh
this might disrupt my sleep but in fact
it didn't I came back I showered had a
little bit of food which normally I
don't eat that late and I slept like a
baby and I felt great the next day
waking up at my normal time which cues
me to another important scientific fact
that relates to protocol and protocol
flexibility which is something that I
gleaned from a colleague of mine at
Stanford School of Medicine who works in
the Sleep laboratory and I intend to
have him as a guest on this podcast
which is that much of our subjective
feelings of energy and well-being during
the day have to do not just with how
well and how much we slept the night
before but how positively we view our
previous days experiences and how
positively we view our next day and in
fact that same day Pursuits and
experiences so in other words how we
feel about our previous day performance
and how we feel about what we're about
to embark on during our day can increase
our energy and that might seem obvious
to a number of you but these days as I
and many others out there are talking so
much about the importance of sleep which
is of course essential you do want to
get great sleep as many nights of your
life as you possibly can and if you
don't sleep much for a given night
hopefully it's for reasons that you
enjoy and positive things like a party
or a wedding or you know use your
imagination but it's also the case that
when we successfully complete something
that we told ourselves that we are going
to do we feel great about it and that if
it means that we sleep a little bit less
or that we have to do our practice bout
you know at 3: p.m. or 2 p.m. a time of
day when we're really ordinarily in the
trough of attention and we have to use
20 different tools or one tool 20
different times in order to get through
that bout of learning the fact that we
complete it leaves us with a feeling of
accomplishment and I'm certain although
I don't know exactly which that there
are neurochemicals and hormones that
reflect that it's almost with certainty
going to involve dopamine and other
neurochemicals but the point is not to
get reductionist about it the point is
that yes heightened attention and focus
occur naturally 30 minutes 3 hours and
11 hours after waking but the really
important thing about all of this goal
setting and pursuit is to do it to get
it done to set the goal to do it
specifically make it quantifiable when
you're going to do it make it about verb
States and then simply do it thank you
for joining me for today's discussion
all about science-based protocols for
how to set and pursue your goals if
you're learning from Andor enjoying this
podcast please subscribe to our YouTube
channel that's a terrific zeroc costway
to support us in addition please
subscribe to the podcast on both Spotify
and apple and on both Spotify and apple
you can leave us up to a five-star
review if you have questions for me or
comments about the podcast or guests
that you'd like me to consider hosting
on the hubman Lab podcast please put
those in the comment section on YouTube
I do read all the comments please also
check out the sponsors mentioned at the
beginning and throughout today's episode
that's the best way to support this
podcast not on today's podcast but on
many previous episodes of The hubman Lab
podcast we discuss supplements while
supplements aren't necessary for
everybody many people derive tremendous
benefit from them for things like
improving sleep hormone support and
focus the hubman Lab podcast has
partnered with momentous supplements if
you'd like to access the supplements
discussed on the hubman Lab podcast you
can go to live momentus spelled o us so
it's lives.com huberman and you can also
receive 20% off again that's live mous
spelled o us.com huberman if you haven't
already subscribed to our neural network
newsletter our neural network newsletter
is a completely zero cost monthly
newsletter that includes summaries of
podcast episodes as well as protocols
that is short PDFs describing for
instance tools to improve sleep tools to
improve neuroplasticity we talk about
deliberate cold exposure Fitness various
aspects of mental health again all
completely zero cost and to sign up you
simply go to hubman lab.com go over to
the menu in the corner scroll down to
newsletter and provide your email we do
not share your email with anybody if
you're not already following me on
social media I am huberman lab on all
platforms so that's Instagram Twitter
threads LinkedIn and Facebook and at all
of those places I talk about science and
science related tools some of which
overlaps with the content of the
huberman Lab podcast but much of which
is distinct from the content of the
huberman Lab podcast again it's huberman
lab on all social media platforms thank
you for joining me today for our
discussion about science-based protocols
for how to best set and pursue and
achieve your goals and I do want to wish
you all the best of luck in setting
pursuing and achieving your goals and
last but certainly not least thank you
for your interest in
[Music]
science